Hello world,
it's to Raj and today I'm going to show
you the five steps to succeed in any
programming interview.
I've gone through the interview process
dozens of times for a bunch of different
tech companies and I've definitely
gotten my fair share of rejections and
offers. These are the key lessons
I've learned from the gate.
Interviewing takes work. Don't let
anyone tell you it's easy. It's not.
No one talks about the rejections,
only their offers.
It's essentially a full time job,
but if you follow these steps,
I promise you you will succeed.
So let's start with step one.
Study before you even think about
applying anywhere you need to get your
technical skills on point.
The process of getting a job as a software
engineer is the same at almost every
big tech company.
You do an initial phone screen with the
recruiter where they gauge your interest
in the company and if you pass that,
you're asked a series of technical
questions that you write answers to on a
whiteboard.
If you can show the interviewer that you
can think through a problem and come up
with a solid solution,
you'll get an offer.
But the only way to do
that is to practice.
All my friends who ended up working
for Austin companies practice a lot.
They start to a consistent study schedule.
It's not about having
some divine intellect,
it's about how much time and
effort you put into studying.
So the question is what do you need to
practice if they're not testing you on
syntax, you could learn basic ruby
syntax overnight if you want it to,
but what can't be taught overnight or
computer science fundamentals and that's
what companies test you on.
Namely data structures and algorithms.
There is no getting around this.
Just ask the guy who invented homebrew,
he was rejected by Google because he
didn't know how to invert a binary tree.
Even though tons of engineers at Google
use his tool daily start off by taking
two courses.
I recommend a free intro
to data structures course
by my code school and the
intro to algorithms course by Mit.
Open courseware.
Both are available on Youtube and we'll
give you broad knowledge about these
topics.
Then you can practice what you've
learned on hacker rank and hacker earth,
both our online platforms that let
you earn points for solving problems.
It's a lot of fun actually. Once you've
solved dozens of problems on both sides,
read programming, interviews, exposed.
Then in cracking the coding interview,
both are great books that will help you
practice specific problems that tend to
show up a lot during interviews from
system designed to questions about time
complexity and when you're done,
start conducting some mock
interviews with the friend,
have them pick questions and code your
answer on a whiteboard explaining your
thought process to them. You can do
all this in about two months, two,
three months of studying
a couple hours every day.
Step two is to find the companies that
you like. When you start the job hunt,
you have a limited amount of time you
can dedicate to each company so you don't
want to waste it. Interviewing for
companies that aren't exciting,
keeping track of the interview process
across multiple companies can be really
stressful unless you stay organized.
Use an excel spreadsheet to map out the
companies on your radar and where you
are in the interview
process with each of them.
You can find these companies on angel
list, which is my favorite resource. Also,
hacker news has a monthly who's hiring,
which is great.
This is a somewhat spiritual process.
You'll probably go through
some existential thoughts
and that's okay. Ultimately,
it's about deciding how you can best use
your skills to make a positive impact
in an area you care about and then
finding companies that align with those
values. Once you've got a
list of companies, it's time
to build your portfolio.
Recruiters that popular companies get
hundreds of resumes every day so they
don't have time to sift
through irrelevant stuff.
Make sure every single word on your
resume count and it all fits on one page.
Make it dense in descriptive. Remember,
the less work they have to do,
the more likely they'll
be to help you out.
Make it easy for them and highlight
the most important work you've done.
You don't have to fit every single
cs related thing you've done on it.
Whatever you put down,
you should be able to speak intelligently
about because all of it is fair game.
During the interview,
have between two to five versions of your
resume each tailored to what a certain
category of companies from your list. Once
personal projects, hackathon projects,
contributions to open source libraries.
Get hub is where you can put your code,
where your mouth is.
It's the new resume in many respects.
Have a personal website and give
your best project a web presence.
It's professional and
visualizations always impress.
Step four is to get the interview.
The easiest way to do this is to just
apply to a company directly through their
website,
but big companies get so many interviewees
that it's really easy to get lost in
the pile. You want to find the
gatekeeper, that technical recruiter,
you can use a little bit of keyword
magic and Google just like this and it'll
give you a list of recruiters and people
in positions you're interested in at
any company.
Send them an email and make sure your
email is short and to the point that means
they quick intro,
introducing who you are.
I'll link to and easily shareable and
relevant project and an expression of
interest to learn more, which brings
us to step five. Pass the interview.
You want to exude confidence and if you've
studied well and your portfolio is on
point,
you will sometimes the interviewer will
be more nervous than you are and that's
okay. Smile, shake hands,
let them know that you're another
human and you're here to work through a
problem together.
They'll ask you to code a problem on a
whiteboard and you want to be able to
communicate your thought process well.
It's not about the answer as much as
it is about the way that you think.
That's what they're judging you on.
Once you've coated your first solution,
pretty much every time they'll ask if
there's a more efficient solution or
usually is,
and this is where your computer science
fundamentals will come in handy and
don't forget to ask questions.
They're there to help you.
It's a collaborative approach.
They're judging your technical skills,
but they're also judging if they could
see themselves working with you and if
you've come prepared,
you'll do just fine.
There are tons of resources on the web
to help you practice your technical
skills. And I've linked to everything
I've talked about here in the description.
The interview game takes a lot of effort.
The key is to not let your rejections
ever, ever, ever, ever get you down.
Because with the enough practice, you
can succeed at any technical interview,
believe in yourself, stay motivated,
and you're going to make it. For now,
I've got to interview someone for
the channel, so thanks for watching.